the cabinet office minister and
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
michael gove is with us this morning
hello
hello good morning good morning good
morning why are you right when so many
of your back bench
and so many of your back benches are
wrong well i i don't think it's binary
like that i think there are a range of
views obviously
in the house of commons in the country
about how we tackle coronavirus
um and we make sure that we listen
respectfully to
uh not just mps but others in order to
try to come with the
the right strategy but i do think we do
have the right strategy which is to make
sure that we
bear down on the virus and ensure that
the nhs is not overwhelmed
it was right to take action with the
national lockdown very painful though it
is for
for many in order to make sure that the
infection rate which was doubling over
time
was brought under control but you can't
convince them so they're not going to
vote with you
um later on well i hope that not just me
but uh uh others who are representing
the government no sure sure absolutely
i hope we will be able to convince as
many people as possible to support the
government today because i think it's
it's critically important that we have
uh these uh
tough but fair tears in place in order
to ensure
that we can continue to beat back the
virus the vaccine is coming
over the hill um with vaccination we
will be able to uh get life
back to normal and with the vaccines so
soon
or rather coming so soon um then it's
really important that we
we don't lose the discipline that we
have now and the ability to ensure that
our nhs is there for people
particularly in the very tough months of
january and february okay i want to come
back to
uh to um uh vaccines in a little while
if i may but i want to talk about tears
first of all
um did you want london to be in tier
three well we never discuss what happens
in cabinet no no of course but the whole
point about cabinet committees is that
uh
the discussions there are private but
the one thing that i will say is that
um it's always easier to move an area
from a tougher tier to a lower tier once
we're
confident that the infection is under
control rather than relaxing things and
then having to
put the brakes on again as we've seen in
wales so in wales they had
uh a two-week clock but i think i think
the welsh comparison shows what happens
okay when you i wonder what you pulled
pull the restraint back too far yeah as
far as the capital is concerned
do you think it should have been in tier
three no i think the right decision was
taken um i think that
the uh proportionate approach is to make
sure that we have tier two
um which is effective at stabilizing and
in some cases
reducing the infection rate is right for
london
um but i think we need to keep all of
these things under view but i'm
confident
that the efforts that we're making now
will ensure that those areas
in tier three over time if we bring the
infection under control in those areas
can be lower and as i say the the lesson
from
from wales which we're all watching and
you know we have friends and relatives
there
is that too rapid a relaxation
means that you have to slam the brakes
on again and the one thing that we all
want to avoid is another
national lockdown is it definitely not
going to happen
another national lockdown i'm as
confident as confident can be
because your juice just wasn't really
out yesterday well i'm as confident as
confident can be
that we won't need one because the tiers
that we have now
are pretty robust so we know that these
new tougher tier three measures
will bring infection rates down we know
that in
tier two things are stable and indeed in
some cases
declining as well and that means we're
on the right trajectory with the
infection moving
in the right way we've still got a lot
of people out there who are infected
a lot of people in hospital and we need
to make sure that the nhs is there
in january and in february for people
who have other conditions as well
can you rule it out um you can never
rule anything out in politics but as i
say
i'm pretty confident on the basis of the
uh
the rigor with which these new tiers are
replying that we can prevent a national
lockdown
one thing i fear though would be that if
we were to relax
the situation uh too rapidly um then we
would have the situation
uh which we've had in some other
countries and indeed in wales
where you have to slam the brakes on
again but that happened here didn't it
in october
well you're absolutely right one of the
problems we can't really doubt well
i think the distinction between what
happened on october and what's happening
now
is that the tier system in october was
not quite as rigorous
as the one that we have now um and also
uh there were many more areas in in tier
one and we know that in the old tier one
uh there was a risk that infections
would rise and it was rising the
infection
rate was rising in every part of the
country
when we had to go into that national
lockdown okay hospitality industry
massively important at this time of year
massive confusion
about what you can and can't do in tier
two what is a substantial meal please
tell me do you like scotch eggs
i love scotch eggs but one of the things
they're horrible i hate them so if i'm
not going to eat that what else can i
eat that's substantial
well there are a whole range of things
okay we can go out together and
um i can take you through a range of
substantial meals but the the definition
of a substantial meal what about garlic
bread
well i believe it's the future i've
tried it well
let's shave the garlic baguette
alongside whatever else lasagna prawn
linguini
whatever but the serious point is that
um
the definition of a substantial meal has
been there in law for some time um
if you were unable to take our uh 16 or
17 year old out to the pub
we could order an alcoholic drink for
them
alongside the substantial meal that they
have
and that is a a well understood
definition
in the hospitality trade what
constitutes
a drink is it a bottle of wine um well
it it it depends what you're celebrating
but the the critical thing here
is that so you could sit and drink a
bottle of wine all night couldn't you
well
uh we've made it clear i think george
mainly told you this yesterday that
the the broad principle is this that uh
you're allowed to
finish a drink um that you've been
enjoying with your substantial meal
but what you can't do is order drinks
after 10 o'clock
drinks that you've ordered with your
meal you can consume and
you can make sure that you've got the
period between 10 and 11
uh to leave in an orderly fashion who is
going to police whether or not i eat my
meal i might order a meal but not eat it
uh well again the rules have been in
place for for children
so if i don't eat my meal am i still
allowed to drink my drink
well again i you can see how confusing
it is well i i can see that um
of course people can always uh ask
questions about
um whether or not they should finish
their meal whether or not they've eaten
half of it does that count as having
eaten a substantial tell me i don't know
do you think it does
um i think common sense is the right
answer here so what's the answer well
as as has been the case when people have
um ordered meals for
16 and 17 year old children when they've
been uh
ordering alcoholic drinks for them uh
the law is pretty clear
um and common sense would prevail i
think we all know that there have been
some occasions in the past when they've
been
uh individual places that have been
you know operating way beyond the rules
and um you know operating as kansai
nightclubs
appropriate action has been taken there
um but also i think that
uh the truth is that uh the overwhelming
majority
nearly everyone i know who's involved in
the hospitality trade uh takes their
responsibilities
seriously and so the rules are pretty
clear so if we went
out for dinner together we could have a
scotch egg a garlic bread and two
bottles of wine and we'd be fine
um well i think we might have a headache
in the morning but um but i think the
the the point is again a substantial
meal is
a well understood definition one that's
been there in law for years
okay do i need to have um a vaccine
passport in order to go to the pub
no will i need to no um i i think the
most important thing to do is to make
sure that we vaccinate as many people as
possible
there are three uh vaccines that are
going through
appropriate testing now to make sure
that they're absolutely safe
and the most important thing is to make
sure that we get people um
as many people as possible starting with
the the most vulnerable and then those
who work in the front line of the nhs
vaccinated effectively okay will i need
to have a vaccine passport to go to the
theater or to go to a sporting event
no i don't think so no um how are you
going to convince people to have these
vaccines because
there's a significant minority who don't
want to have them yes there are and i
think that's a big challenge because
we've got to
persuade people um uh who are uh opposed
to taking a vaccine that it's
uh in the all of our collective interest
um we all know that there's been this
issue
um with uh measles in the past we know
that if you don't have
uh as many people vaccinated as possible
there are measles outbreaks
um i think that um uh we can take on
some of the arguments from the
the anti-vaxx brigade they're not really
based in science
uh there's a very rigorous process that
we undergo in order to make sure
vaccines are safe sorry
perception is reality that's the problem
isn't it well the you know
but are you going to use celebrities to
try to get people to have a vaccine
because people don't trust politicians i
find that difficult to believe but
apparently that's the case
well i think it's certainly the case
that um people sometimes take with a
pinch of salt
um some of the the things that
politicians of any party say which is
why i think it's important that
we're led by the science and we're led
by uh the authoritative
authoritative evidence um that vaccines
work which celebrities do you think
might convince the british public
um well i think you would okay but
but beyond that um uh uh i'm not i'm not
sure that i should be
uh celebrity picking um i think the most
important thing is to concentrate
on the quality of the arguments um you
know people in this country
um uh have common sense uh the
overwhelming majority
can see that um getting vaccinated is
not just good for you
it's also good for others it's a way of
making sure uh that granny and grandad
mum and dad are safer
okay so there won't be a vaccine
passport no that's not being planned
at all ever uh well happening not
happening
i don't know uh uh i certainly am not
planning to introduce any vaccine
passports and i don't know anyone else
in government
okay let's talk about brexit what are
the remaining sticking points
um well there are three really um the
first is fisheries um
uh the eu still want to take the lion's
share of the fish in our waters which is
just not fair given that we're
we're leaving the eu um the second thing
is
uh some of the eu rules the eu still
want us uh to be tied to their way of
doing things um and then the third thing
is what happens if there's a
dispute the eu um uh are at the moment
reserving the right if there's any sort
of dispute
to uh not quite rip everything up but
really to impose some quite sort of
penal
and tough restrictions on us and we
don't think that's fair
i know that fishing is very close to
your heart obviously given uh family
connections um so i did look up a little
bit about fishing
um more than 160 million pounds worth of
the english fishing quota
is in the hands of vessels by companies
based in iceland spain
and the netherlands and we're talking
about 12 000
british fishermen as opposed to 13 000
jobs that are potentially going from
arcadia
tomorrow are we are we over playing our
hand on fishing
no i don't think so i i think it's the
case that if you if you look also at
some of the european countries
you can also say that the number of
people employed in in fisheries in
in in their economies is relatively
small but
uh it matters hugely to this country
that we have given our heritage and also
given the potential
that we have in managing our own waters
not just to revive coastal communities
but also to manage
our seas in a more environmentally
sensitive way it really matters that we
get this right
and there's no reason why we can't be a
country like iceland
like norway which manage access to their
own waters it's part of being an
independent country
but we did sell off quite a lot of our
fishing rights didn't we in the 90s i
think wasn't it well
yeah there are some people who have sold
their questions but they the broader
point is
that ultimately we as a country should
decide who comes into our waters
we're not saying that there shouldn't be
any boats from any european country
it's just that you know like our
neighbors in norway and our friends in
iceland
they're able to say look we're an
independent country these are our waters
if you if you want to come in we can
negotiate that
but ultimately um uh this belongs to us
what i'm saying to counter that is that
i understand that but there are only 12
000 british
fishermen at the moment at the moment uh
indeed
and also we sold off quite a lot of our
fishing rights um
some 20 odd years ago uh
countering that 13 000 jobs potentially
going in arcadia
20 000 extra alcohol-related deaths
because of covid
19 and the lockdowns here in the united
kingdom are we getting it in proportion
i think so yes i mean i think the the
arcadia story is a tragic one
um and uh i'm not going to criticize any
individual but um
there's been a lot of reporting that
points out some of the you know the the
missteps that have been made by the
management there
more broadly we know that the high
school you like philip green uh i'm not
going to get into personalities but i
think that um
uh we know that there's been a problem
with the management
there but we know more broadly to be
fair um that the high street is facing
unprecedented pressure part of that is
a significant part of that of course is
covered that's why i think it's good
news more broadly
um that uh shops will reopen um uh on
wednesday
if we get the new tier system through um
and you make the point about covered
related deaths and again
that's why we're taking the steps that
we are in order to try to reduce
infection
um you've got to do all of these things
at once negotiate a fair brexit
deal with covid and also trying to
provide support to to people who are
working in retail
why does the government feel that philip
green's mismanaged arcadia
well there's a broader question about
the management um of arcadia
um but uh as i say i'm not going to get
into the personalities of it i think
most analysts would say that they've
been some missteps along the way
um two very quick questions if i may
rita ora i got in terrible trouble
because of her 30 birth
30th birthday bash yes thought on her uh
well she's apologized um um i'm very
graciously
um and so i think i think we can leave
it there i mean she's an um incredibly
talented singer she made a mistake
we all make mistakes she apologized so i
think you know
you can let that be okay and finally um
in september
last time i spoke to you you said that
if i was free on christmas day i should
come round
yes well um we're allowed to have three
bubbles
um uh or three households in the bubble
um
if you really want to uk then i'll have
a word with my wife
and but i suspect you've probably got
many many better offers on it
is the room still at the table uh we
haven't decided all our christmas
arrangements but if you want to come
around i'll i'll have a word with sarah
um and um uh make the case
but as i said i suspect you've got less
you did you did promise
yeah no no no sure no but but i think
you probably you always keep your word
yeah yeah but um if you really really
want to kay
we will be we'll do everything to make
sure it happens
but as i say um you know i'll bring a
big bottle of wine it'll only count as
wondering
okay that's fine all right then you're
definitely good it's good to talk to you
thanks so much for joining us thank you
very much appreciated as always thank
you